Bitte schön.
Äh, normal, ist das für Sie?
Tabii. Hallo Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Kapaghan. Ich bin hier als Dienstabendarzt tätig.
Und wir werden gerne mit Ihnen das Analyse geschrafen führen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, dann können Sie gerne mir Bescheid sagen.
Bevor wir über Ihre Aktuelle Becher...
Ich verstehe Sie nicht.
Okay, genau. Sie haben das ja.
Bevor wir über Ihre Aktuelle Becher werden, ich möchte ganz schnell ein paar Argumente fragen.
Sie sind damit einfach, ich dann...
Wie ist Ihr Name nochmal, bitte?
Mein Name ist Kapaghan.
Kapa, was?
Kapaghan. Was bedeutet das den Kapaghan?
Kapaghan, ja.
Woher kommt?
Außer Türkei.
Wir sind in der Türkei.
Genau, eine Name von türkischer Geschichte.
Was machen Sie hier in Deutschland?
Hier in Deutschland. Ich möchte hier arbeiten.
Seit zwei Jahren bin ich in Deutschland.
Haben Sie keine Arbeit bei Ihnen zu Hause?
Jetzt arbeite ich in einem Krankenhaus in der Physiatrie.
Erst seitdem habe ich eingefangen.
Ich brauche keine Ausländer hier in Deutschland.
Ich bleibe, wo Sie sind.
Wir haben hier eigene Ärzte, die so an hier arbeiten.
Ja, genau. Ich verstehe Sie, aber natürlich, einerseits gibt es viele deutsche Ärzte,
aber andererseits werden viele ausländische oder deutsche Ärzte auch von Krankenhäusern gesucht.
Deshalb, ich glaube, viele Krankenhäuser brauchen...
Ich bin ja ein deutschen Arzt.
Ich möchte nicht von einem deutschen Arzt behandelt werden.
Wenn Sie andere Ärzte möchten, können wir auch andere Ärzte gucken.
Können wir auch Ihnen anbieten.
Aber ich muss zuerst mit einem Oberarzt sprechen.
Wir arbeiten hier als Team.
Deshalb beschäftigen wir nicht nur...
Ist der Oberarzt ein Deutscher Arzt?
Wie bitte?
Genau. Unser Oberarzt ist ein Deutscher Arzt, aber er hat viel zu tun.
Deshalb, ich bin zuständig für Sie.
Aber natürlich werde ich mit dem Oberarzt sprechen.
Wir reden ja noch relativ gut Deutschmann.
Versteht Sie ja recht gut.
Wenn der Oberarzt ein Deutscher Arzt ist, dann können wir heute mal eine Ausnahme machen.
Okay, danke Ihnen.
Aber ich verstehe Sie natürlich.
Jeder will beste Betrug haben.
Deshalb, ich verstehe Sie.
Aber natürlich, unser Team und unsere Kollegen auch beschäftigen über viele Fälle.
Ich bin jetzt für Sie hier.
Und wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Franz Martin Meier.
Franz Martin Meier.
Ybd.
M.A. Y. Emil Richard Meier.
Okay.
Könnten Sie Ihr Vornamen bestabieren?
Franz Friedrich Richard Anton Nordpol Zippelin.
Okay.
Und Martin und Meier.
Herr Meier.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Waren genau sind Sie geboren?
Muss ich Ihnen das noch mal sagen?
Herr Götzak, Herr Meier, das haben Sie doch bei Ihnen unterlagend.
Ja, ich kann gucken.
15. August.
1907.
Okay, genau.
14. August.
1952.
Ja.
Nee, 1970.
Sie sind jetzt 52 Jahre alt.
Ja, 52, Sie haben recht.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich wiege 98 Kilo.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich glaube, 1 Meter 76.
Okay.
Herr Meier, was führt Sie zu uns?
Was führt Sie bei Schwerte?
Also, Doktor, wenn Sie mich so direkt fragen,
ich habe seit einer Woche zunehmende Schmerzen
im linken Unterbauch,
der Straten hier von hinten,
so nach vorne, aus dem Gürtel.
Okay.
Und wie geht es Ihnen?
Sie kommen,
ich kann es nicht richtig sagen.
Das kommt vom Rücken,
das ist immer da.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl,
es kommt vom Rücken.
Dort tut es auch weh.
Ja.
Und wenn Sie mich Richtung HoDenSack.
HoDenSack, ja.
Dort tut es weh.
Darin habe ich auch Statisch mehr.
Linken HoDenSack, ja.
Ja, ich habe ein wenig Sitze.
Ich bin Geschäftsmann, ich muss sehr viel Autofahrern,
ich muss jetzt in meine Kundschaft.
Ja, okay, fertig.
eine Stunde Autofahrer, dass mir das Bein wehtut. Ich kann danach kaum laufen und da habe ich starke Schmerzen.
Genau. Wenn Sie laufen, bekommen Sie diese Schmerzen, ja?
Egal, ob ich stehe, ob ich laufe, ob ich sitze.
Okay. Und sind die Schmerzen drückend oder können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ach, das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Das ist manchmal so wellenförmig. Es kommt und geht.
Manchmal strahlt es aus. Das ist immer da.
Okay. Und sind die Schmerzen drückend oder brennend oder dumpf?
Kann ich nicht sagen, eher dumpf, würde ich sagen.
Ja, okay. Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei ein sehr leichter und sehr, sehr starker Schmerz meint?
Also das ist immer sehr unterschiedlich. Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, es geht so Richtung 8, 9, manchmal sind es nur 2, 3. Aber es ist immer da.
Okay, genau. Verstehe ich. Immer dauerhaft. Und auch, hätte Sie, habe Sie die Schmerzen im Laufe der Tageszeit schlechter, ja?
Ja, genau.
Und es hilft auch nichts, Herr Doktor. Ich habe schon so viel Schmerzen mit die Kaminthie genommen. Ich bekomme schon Magenschmerzen.
Genau, ja, verstehe ich. Welche Medikamente habe Sie denn angemessen?
Wie viel Medikamente haben Sie denn angemessen?
Als ich zu Hause hatte, über Profäen, da habe ich pro Tag so 3, 4 Stück genommen, hat aber nichts gebracht. Dann habe ich mit Ihnen hingefunden.
Und die habe ich auch genommen, aber auch da habe ich nur gar für eine kurze Zeit Schmerzlinderung gehabt.
Ja, wie viel Medikamente habe ich auch genommen, habe alles nichts gebracht.
Über Profäen haben Sie eingegangen und noch etwas?
Novalgin, ja, okay. Können Sie erinnern, dass die, wie viel, was, oder in welche Dosierung haben Sie eingegangen?
Ich meine, über Profäen. Ja, über Profäen und Novalgin.
Aber auch, je was war, ich glaube, das waren 600 Milligramm.
600, genau, ja. Okay.
Und Novalgin, darf ich fragen, auch, wie viele, in welche Dosierung haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich muss auch diese notieren, deshalb würde ich fragen.
Weiß ich nicht, Herr Doktor. Novalgin, soweit ich habe eine Dosierung von Novalgin.
Alles klar.
Das waren 500.
500, genau.
Und jetzt haben Sie Schmerzen, starker Schmerzen, können Sie diese Schmerzen aushalten, bis du sehr gespielt, zu Ende ist?
Noch geht es, aber ich denke, das wird jetzt wieder zunehmen, ja, aber im Moment ist es noch raus.
Genau, wenn Sie sich starker Schmerzen haben, können Sie gerne mir welche sagen, dann können wir etwas machen.
Okay, vielen Dank, Herr Doktor. Sie sind ja ganz nett, Herr Doktor, hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Danke Ihnen, ja.
Ab so freundlich ist, naja, Danke Ihnen, ja.
Deshalb würde ich sagen, ausländischer Erste auch können etwas Gute heranlangen.
Na ja, nicht so schnell, Herr Doktor, ganz langsam, jetzt warten wir mal.
Okay, ja.
Und ich muss Ihre Beschwerde konzentrieren, auf Ihre Beschwerde konzentrieren und Sie haben, ich werde voll mich dumm.
Haben Sie etwas aus, ja, Siedlich-Schmerzen, narusabhängig oder bewegungsabhängig, lagerabhängig?
Das ist unabhängig also, es ist egal, ob ich stehe, ob ich sitze, es tut immer weh.
Immer tut ich weh, okay.
Wenn ich die Position ändere, dann wird es für eine kurze Zeit besser, aber dann geht es wieder los.
Genau, ja.
Und gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für diese Schmerzen?
Kann ich nicht sagen, das hat langsam angefangen.
Es ist jetzt soweit gekommen, jetzt in einer Woche, zehn Tage jetzt.
Langsam angefangen und ja, okay.
Haben Sie, okay, in der letzten Zeit Zäckenwissen gehabt?
Zäckenwissen, nicht, dass ich immer rein.
Okay, und Sie haben gesagt, dass die Schmerzen Gürtel vor mich ist, oder?
Das habe ich richtig verstanden, oder?
Also es zieht von hinten nach vorne wie ein Gürtel, ja.
Ein Gürtel, okay.
Ich habe aber keinen Ausschlag, ne?
Keinen Ausschlag, ja, okay.
Und Hautverfärbung, auch, haben Sie nicht bemerkt?
Hautverfärbung oder Jugendleite oder Gerbshut?
Außen von der Haut sieht man nichts.
Genau, Gerbshut in Ihren Augen, auch, haben Sie nicht bemerkt.
Ich kann auch suchen, genau, ich, ja, okay, alles klar.
Meine Augen, ganz weiß.
Ja.
Und wussten Sie?
Nein, ansonsten habe ich eigentlich nichts.
Haben Sie Fieber oder Schütterfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Fieber habe ich nicht gehabt, aber mir war es am Anfang, habe ich so ein bisschen,
das Gefühl gehabt, ich kriege eine Erkältung, aber das war gleich wieder weg.
Am Anfang, vor einer Woche, ja?
Ja.
Geht aber nicht, jetzt habe ich nichts.
Okay.
Leider sind Sie unter Luftnot oder Brustmaßchen oder so?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine Beschwerden und glücklicherweise auch keine Medikamente.
Okay, das ist schon.
Und leider sind Sie unter saueres Ausstoß oder Sortrennen oder Völle gefühlt?
Ja, das habe ich manchmal, wenn ich etwas mehr Wein trinke oder so,
aber ansonsten nicht, auch im Moment nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schmerzen, Weinwasser lassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Also da habe ich im Moment kein Problem, nein.
Stuhlgang klappt gut, Wasser lassen auch.
Okay, das ist schön.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit in der letzten Zeit?
Das ist gut, da hat sich nichts geändert.
Nein.
Das ist schön.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewollt ab oder zugenommen?
Nein.
Okay, das ist gut.
wäre schön, wenn ich ein bisschen abnehmen könnte, aber...
Haben Sie nicht geschafft?
Okay.
Leider sind unter Verstoffung oder Durchfall?
Nein.
Haben Sie Unaufwähliges im Stuhl bemerkt oder frische?
Das ist ein aufwähliges.
Genau, aufwähliges.
Wie immer, als normal.
Okay, genau.
Das ist frisches Blut oder so, haben Sie nicht bemerkt?
Ach so, nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie erbrochen?
Sie meinten jetzt, diese eine Woche.
Genau, in der letzten Zeit.
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen auch nichts gewindlich?
Nein, nein, das habe ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Ich möchte kurz zusammen mit der Fassung über Ihre Beschwerden
machen, für Sie machen, dann würde ich weiter machen.
Seit einer Woche haben Sie diese Beschwerden
und vor einer Woche sind die Schmerzen
plötzlich langsam aufgetreten, in den linken Unterbauch,
dann strahlten die Schmerzen in den Rücken,
dann seit zwei Tagen haben Sie auch eine Schmerz in Haudensack.
Genau, links, Haudensack.
Und jetzt haben Sie, im ganzen Bauch haben Sie Schmerzen, oder?
Es ist mehr links.
Okay, wie Gürtel vor mich, haben Sie beschrieben.
Und wählen für mich, immer manchmal kommen und gehen wieder weg.
Aber immer die Schmerzen bleiben, die Schmerzattacken manchmal
gehen auch wieder weg.
Und Sie haben etwas aufsprobieren, Medikamente eingenommen
und diese Schmerzen schon linden, aber das haben auch nicht gut geholfen.
Okay.
Und das habe ich richtig verstanden, ja?
Alles richtig.
Ja, alles richtig.
Ich möchte jetzt zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte etwas fragen.
Leiden Sie an eine bestimmte Vorerkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte, zum Beispiel Bluthochdrück,
Schilddrösen über Funktionen oder Leberkrankheit?
Ich habe keine weiteren Erkrankungen.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Nein, ich mag keine Medikamente und ich liebe auch keine Medikamente.
Ich habe jetzt eine Schmerz, wie gesagt, ein bisschen eingenommen.
Okay, ich bin jetzt auf dem Nr. 12.
Ja.
Okay, und sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Oh, ich glaube, als Kind hat man mir die Mandelmal entfernt,
aber ansonsten nicht.
Okay, okay, das ist schön.
Sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Ja, ich glaube eine tolle Allergie und gegen Katzenhaare.
Ja, okay.
Wie erscheint diese Allergie bei Ihnen?
Ja, ich kriege immer so ein Nies-Anfall, meine Nase juckt.
Ich lasse die Wasser aus der Nase, meine Augen brennen.
Okay.
Wie Linitis, ja.
Was ist Linitis, weiß ich nicht, aber...
Ja, wie Linitis, ja.
Einen, ja, wie Nasenentzündung können wir auch sagen,
aber das ist nicht gleich, aber ein ähnliches Entzündung, ja.
Das wollte ich von uns sagen.
Und leiden Sie oder ist Ihnen Unverkündlichkeiten bekannt?
Wie meinen Sie das, Unverträglichkeiten?
Gegen bestimmte Lebensmittel, manchmal können wir...
Nee, nee, ich bin wie ein Mädresscher, ich kann alles essen und trinken,
wirklich herweise habe ich da keine Probleme.
Okay, das ist schön.
Laufen Sie?
Ja.
Wie viele Schäfte, Pakum, wie viele Pakum?
Wenn ich ehrlich sein darf, ungefähr eine Schachtel am Tag.
Okay, seit wann?
Oh, Doktor, ich glaube seitdem ich seit meinem Studium war,
da war ich, glaube ich, 22, also...
Wow.
Dann sind das, glaube ich, 30 Jahre.
Du, glaube ich, nicht so viel geraucht, jetzt habe ich viel Stress, aber...
Ja, genau, okay.
Ich empfehle Ihnen, mit dem Lauch und aufzuhören.
Ja, ja, das versuche ich schon seit ein paar Jahren, aber irgendwie schaffe ich das nicht.
Ich habe einfach viel zu viel Stress, Doktor.
Ja, verstehe, genau, ja, verstehe, aber natürlich.
Ja, und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ab und zu mal, ja.
Wie viele Gläschen?
Aber zum Abendessen mal ein Gläschen, ein Bein oder so.
Okay, das ist nicht schlimm, ja, das ist kein Problem.
Und bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine medisische Frage.
Ich muss Sie fragen, ob Sie Droge nehmen?
Droge?
Nein, da kann ich ganz offen, ein Droge habe ich keine.
Okay, das ist schön.
Herr Meyer, und treiben Sie Sport?
Nein.
Okay.
Ich habe mal früher mal ein Fußballer gespielt, aber keine Zeit.
Ja, jetzt keine Zeit, ja, verstehe ich.
Aber wenn wir jetzt Sport treiben können, wäre das besser eigentlich für Sie.
Ja, schauen wir mal.
Genau.
Und wie ist die Impfstattung?
Oh, Doktor, ich habe keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Gegen Corona haben Sie, wohnen Sie aufrisch geimpft?
Ja, habe ich 2 Impfungen bisher erhoben.
2 Impfungen haben Sie erhoben, aber 3. Impfung haben Sie noch nicht?
Nein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die 3. Impfung wirklich machen lassen soll.
Ja, das wird immer diskutiert eigentlich, jetzt im Fernseher oder im Medien können wir auch lesen.
Das ist Ihre eigene Entscheidung.
Ja, ich empfehle Ihnen, 3. Impfung zu haben.
Ja, mal gucken.
Ja, genau.
Und sind Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, ich war letztes Jahr in Australien.
Oh, letztes Jahr, genau.
Aber haben Sie etwas schlimmer Erkrankungen?
Nein, alles gut, da war jetzt nichts Besonderes.
Okay, das ist schön.
Herr Mayer, jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen über Ihre Familiengeschichte an Sie stellen.
Sie stellen aber viele Fragen, Herr Doktor.
Ja, genau, ich habe auch bemerkt, dass dieses Gespräch ein bisschen lange gedauert ist, aber gedauert hat.
Aber muss ich alle Informationen über Ihre Beschwerden und über Sie haben und zusammen um richtige Diagnose stellen zu können?
Ja, warum kommen wir wegen meinen Beschwerden?
Was kümmert die Familien?
Die Familienerkrankungen muss ich auch notieren, deshalb würde ich fragen.
Das ist aber nur kurze Zeit, nur schnell.
Bitte, bitte.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Ja, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder.
Mhm.
Mit wem wohnen Sie zusammen?
Die Kinder sind noch klein, die wohnen alle noch zu Hause bei uns.
Okay, das ist schön.
Und die Kinder sind gesund, oder?
Ja, glücklicherweise, denen geht es gut.
Und das ist schön.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe nur eine Schwester.
Mhm.
Ist die Schwester gesund?
So weit ich war es ja.
Ich glaube nicht, ich wünschte jetzt nicht, dass sie irgendeine Erkrankung hat.
Ja, genau.
Sie ist auch zehn Jahre jünger als ich.
Ja, ich glaube auch, sie ist gesund.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern leben ja.
Ja, das weiß ich schon.
Und haben Ihre Eltern wichtige Erkrankungen,
wovon ich wissen sollte?
Die Alterserkrankung, mein Vater hat Blutdruck.
Er hat ein bisschen Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen,
Männerprobleme.
Prostata, oder?
Ja, ich glaube.
Meine Mutter, die hat wohl leicht erhöhte Kulisterinwerte,
hat sie mal gesagt, aber ansonsten hat sie jetzt nichts.
Okay, und seit wann haben diese Erkrankungen?
Jeder Vater und er.
Das weiß ich.
Alles klar.
Also ist es kein weiterer Erkrankung,
aber es ist ein weiterer Erkrankung.
Ja, alles klar.
Ansonsten keine weitere Erkrankungen bei Ihnen.
Okay.
Was machen Sie als beruflich?
Herr Meier, sind Sie?
Ich bin selbstständig.
Ich vertreibe medizinische Produkte
und bin daher auch sehr viel unterwegs.
Genau, ja.
Sie verkaufen diese medizinische Produkte, oder?
Ja.
Sind Sie jetzt zufrieden bei der Arbeit, oder haben Sie sich die Trässe?
Ja, es ist schon stressig, aber ich bin zufrieden.
Brauchen Sie eigentliche Gerätschaften oder Corona-Tests?
Ja, ja, werde ich das machen.
Ich kann Ihnen zu einem guten Preis verkaufen, Herr Doktor.
Vielleicht können wir uns einig werden.
Genau, ja.
Oder Ihrer Klinik.
Wenn Sie so ein bisschen behilflich sind,
dann bekommen Sie auch eine kleine Provision.
Ich habe das später.
Vielleicht guckt nachher nochmal Reden darüber.
Genau, ja.
Ja.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Stress oder?
Ich habe noch ein Ultraschallgerät gebraucht
und ich habe noch ein sehr gutes Ultraschallgerät
für Ihre Narben.
Das ist auch schön, das ist gut.
Wir können nach Ihrer Behandlung, nach dieser Prozesse,
können wir auch wieder sprechen darüber.
Wenn Sie ein neues CT haben wollen,
dann habe ich ein sehr gutes Mangebot von Philips.
Das ist sehr schön.
Also dann können wir uns sicherlich für Sie einen guten Preis machen.
Aber ich muss zuerst auf Ihre Beschwerden konstatrieren
und diese Enkonventionen fertig sammeln.
Und haben Sie Schlafströmen oder Durchschlaf-Einschlafströmen?
Ich habe Schlafströmen,
wenn die Kunden ihre Rechnungen nicht zahlen.
Dann bekommt man Schlafströmen.
Wenn sie zahlen, dann geht es mir gut.
Das ist nicht schlimmer Schlafströmen.
Das ist normaler Schlafströmen.
Deshalb brauchen Sie keine Anzuhaben.
Herr Meier, ich habe von meiner Seite fertig.
Ja, sind wir ja fertig.
Endlich noch da.
Genau.
Wenn Sie starker Schmerzen haben,
werde ich Sie so als Köperlisch untersuchen.
Ich werde Sie durchführen und die Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde Sie auch sehen und beurteilen.
Dann können wir Ihnen Schmerzmittel geben.
Zugang legen.
Jetzt werde ich auch sehen.
Ich glaube, langsam werden die Schmerzen auch wieder schlimmer.
Ich glaube, jetzt bräuchte ich einen Schmerz mit die Kaminthalle.
Genau, das werden wir ganz schnell geben.
Ich muss natürlich bei uns bleiben.
So lange kann ich nicht bleiben.
Ich muss bald wieder weiter.
Das dauert ein bisschen.
Deshalb machen wir alles ganz schnell.
Aber müssen Sie natürlich zuerst bleiben.
Um richtige Diarrose stellen zu können.
Aber Abdomen, auch ultrachal werde ich durchführen.
Deshalb dauert ein bisschen.
Was für ein ultrachal Gerät haben Sie hier in den Notaufnahmen?
Siebens oder ist es ein Japanischer?
Philips haben wir.
Philips?
Ja, die sind nicht schlecht.
Aber ich kann Ihnen da etwas von GE Gutes anbieten.
Okay, ich fahr mal an.
Genau, ja.
Das waren meine Fragen.
Sprechen Sie noch mit Ihrem Oberarzt?
Ja, ich werde mit dem Oberarzt sprechen.
Ich habe jetzt auf der Station.
Ich muss ihn anrufen.
Ich werde Sie in die Schlechtferne sprechen.
Ich würde es auch noch mit angucken.
Sie machen einen netten und kompetenten Eindruck.
Aber ich möchte, dass der Oberarzt mit drauf schaut.
Sicherlich, ja.
Ich verstehe.
Ich habe andere Fragen.
Ich habe schon mal ähnliche Beschwerden erlebt.
Nein, das ist erstmalig.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Hoden gerötet, geschwollt oder warm sind?
Gerötet? Nein.
Ich habe nur Schmerzen, aber die Spelung habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Nein.
Bitte verstehen Sie diese Fragen nicht falsch.
Ich muss sie stellen,
weil in deinem Hoden-Schmerz
haben Sie geschwollt, dass Sie heute mit dem wachsenden Partner sind?
Nein, ich bin sehr treu.
Ich habe das nicht.
Wie viel trinken Alkohol Sie am Tag?
Nicht so oft, am Abend, sondern halbis Gläschen Wein.
Wie viel?
Keine Ahnung, schon lange.
Ich habe das nicht.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Geschlechtswerken?
Ich habe eine sehr intime Frage.
Alles in Ordnung, kein Problem.
Ich glaube, Ihnen natürlich.
Können wir uns anfangen, als Herr Schipre?
Ja.
Bitte schön.
Herr Oberarzt, herzlichen Kurs.
Guten Abend.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Ich habe gehört, dass Sie rasistisch sind.
Sie haben etwas grob und unfreundlich.
Ja, genau.
Herr Kollege, Sie müssen gleich Parole geben.
Sie dürfen das nicht gefallen lassen.
Ich bin gewöhnlich.
Ich verstehe, aber ich habe alles erklärt.
Ich habe ein bisschen beruhigt.
Er hat auch überzeugt davon.
Ich glaube, jetzt gibt es kein Problem.
Das hoffe ich mal.
Herr Franz Martin-Mayer ist 52 Jahre alt.
Er hat 98 Kilogramm schwer und 1,76 cm groß.
Herr Franz Martin-Mayer hat sich heute bei uns
wegen seit einer Woche zu nehmender Bauchschmerzen vorgestellt.
Die Schmerzen seien im linken Bauch aufgetreten.
Und danach würden wir uns das nicht mehr tun.
Wir haben seit zwei Tagen eine Schmerz in linksseitiger Hoden Sack.
Seit zwei Tagen.
Die Schmerzen sind in der Schmerz.
Die Schmerzek gehadowsack in oder verschwert nach linksseitiger wird.
Seit zwei Tagen.
Die beiden Schmerzen sind wählen für mich.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt eines Schmerzistas von
1 bis 10 bei 8 wie 9.
Aber wenn Schmerzen gegangen sind,
sind sich die Schmerzskala ein oder zwei.
Eins oder zwei bis zwei. Und zu Hause habe der Patient ein paar Medikamente
eingenommen um diese Schmerzen zu linden. Diese Ibuprofen und Nolagin 600
Milligramm und 500 Milligramm, aber das habe keine Linde gebracht.
Und der Patient habe am Anfang der Schmerzattacken eine
fibrige Gefühl gehabt, aber dann habe er keine Fieber gehabt.
Und ansonsten die Vegat-Stövanamese sei unabfällig und die Schmerzen seien
Gürtel vor mich oder der Patient habe hat die Schmerzen als Gürtel für mich beschrieben.
Ja und die Vorerkrankungen.
Ein Aufschlag hatte ich, den haben Sie angeschaut.
Genau, die Frage nach Second Beasts und Ausschlag wurden verneint und die Frage
nach ähnlicher Beschwerde in der Vergangenheit auch wurden verneint.
Und die Schmerzen auch seien dunkel jetzt.
Und es gebe keine relevante Vorerkrankungen, keine Vorerkrankungen
und der Patient nehme keine regelmäßig Medikamente ein.
Und als Kind sei der Patient abkonspektomiert worden,
ansonsten keine weitere Operationen.
Und der Patient habe eine Polenallergie und Kasehareallergie.
Diese Allergie erscheint sich bei den Patienten eine Rhinokonjuktivitis.
Und der Patient habe zweimal gegen Corona Covid-19 geimpft,
wurde geimpft, aber dritte Impfung habe er noch nicht erhalten.
Und der Patient sei Raucher, seit 30 Jahren Raucher-Einpackung-Sigarette,
das heißt 30 Packung-Jahr und trinke geregentlich Alkohol
und die Drogenkonsum wurde vermeint.
Der Patient sei verheiratet und lebt mit seiner Familie zusammen.
Hab zwei gesunde Kinder und habe eine Schwester, die auch gesund ist.
Und der Vater des Patienten leidet an einer Arteriehypertonie
und die Mutter des Patienten leidet an einer Hypercholesthyrolemi.
Und der Patient sei selbstständiger Arbeiter.
Nicht sehr selbstständig.
Arbeiter selbstständig, genau.
Und verkaufe er medizinische Produkte.
Darf man ihn mal kennenlernen?
Er hat auch etwas davon erzählt, möchte auch kennenlernen.
Und etwas möchte auch natürlich uns kaufen.
Ich habe gesagt, wir können später darüber sprechen,
so dass wir sie behandeln.
Dann müssen wir ihn gut behandeln.
Genau.
Und die Insomnia, Stress und andere Fragen,
die relevanten Fragen wurden vermeint, unauffällig.
Die Analyzischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine akute Appendicitis.
Als Differenzial, die haben nur sehr komisch.
Linker Unterbauch.
Genau, linker, eine Leistungbruch.
Die Analyzischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine...
Doktor, täuschen Sie mich nicht.
Üretiritis, oder?
Üritriatis.
Üretriatis, auch Üretiritis können wir sagen.
Üretiritis, ne, kenn ich nicht.
Üretiritis, was ist das?
Üretiritis.
Auf Deutsch, sag mal den Begriff auf Deutsch.
Ja.
Handleiterstein, meinen Sie, oder?
Handleiterstein, ja, üretriatis.
Üretiroliteasis, okay.
Üretriatis, und die Entsündung der Üretra ist üretri...
Üretra und ureter.
Was wollen Sie wissen?
Ich wollte üretter sagen.
Also der Handleiter, nicht die Handröhre.
Handröhre ist die uretra und Handleiter sind die ureter.
Und die Entsündung der üretra ist üretiritis, oder?
Ich glaube, das nennt sich uretoliteasis, glaube ich.
Die Entsündung.
Ja, ich meine, ja.
Üretritis, nee, uretritis, echt, das kann sein, ja.
Ich bin selbst überübt.
Und die Entsündung der Handröhre,
wie kann man auf diese sagen,
dass man die Entsündung der Handröhre hat, die ich schrieb, glaube ich.
Uretera, das ist doch ureteritis.
Ureteritis, ja, ja.
Ja, üretritis und üretiritis, so haben wir gelandet im Deutschkurs.
Okay, uretra ist die Handröhre, ja.
Ja, uretritis und üretri...
Ureteritis, ja.
Aber da ist, glaube ich, der deutsche Begriff einfacher.
Das ist ein Leiterstein, ne?
Und Entsündung durch einen Handleiterstein.
Ja, okay.
Ist einfacher.
Und die, ja, die, meine Verdachterung ist eine üretiritis,
oder die Entsündung der Handleiterstein.
Und aus der Verdachterung, aus diffinzialer oder so,
kommen eine akutes Pankratitis und ein näherstein.
Eine akutes Pankratitis macht doch keine Hohenschmerzen.
Ja, aber aus Komplikation kann vielleicht etwas auslösen.
Naja, okay.
Deshalb und gürtelförmige Schmerzen.
Meine genitrile, fermigen Schmerzen, okay, ja, gut.
Ja, und auch varikose können wir...
Eine varikosele.
Varikosele, genau, varikosele im Hoden.
Und auch eine Lymphadenitis, Lymphadenitis in diesem Leistenbereich.
Okay.
Können wir auch aus diffinzialer Dognose leschen.
Ein Kollege hat etwas geschrieben.
Aber ein Leistenbruch, wenn Sie schon die Leisten sagen.
Leistenbruch, ja, Leisten herrni können wir auch sagen.
Und die Vertikulität ist natürlich, das erste, woran Sie denken mussten.
Linker Unterbrauch.
Wo ist die Appendix, lieber Kollege?
Appendix ist an der Leiste brauche.
Ich habe akute Pankratitis, wollte ich sagen.
Du hast Appendices gesagt, ja.
Okay, Appendices, ja, habe ich fast geschrieben.
Okay.
Okay, genau, also.
Am Hoden, wo er nicht test ist, sondern eine Nebenhodenentschuldung, wie nennt sich das?
Epiditimitis.
Epiditimitis, genau.
Also Sie haben eine varikosele oder eine spermatrozele, gibt es auch?
Spermatrozele, genau, das auch möglich.
Ein Lipom kann auch dort etwas Schmerzen.
Nicht unbedingt.
Aber der Patient hat doch gesagt, ja genau, eine Rodentausi.
Rodentausi, genau.
Der Patient hat gesagt, die Schmerzen kommen vom Rückhänd nach vorne, strahlen sie aus.
Woran muss man da denken?
Eine...
Vom Rückhänd, von der Lendenwirbelsäule.
Genau, von den Lenden ist eine Ischialgie geschmerzen.
Eine Lumbosischialgie.
Lumbosischialgie, genau.
Lumbosischischialgie.
Kann auch diese testikulare Schmerzen auslösen oder verursachen.
Je nachdem, in welcher Höhe das ist, aber nicht so oft ist mehr die Schmerzen im Bein, natürlich.
Aber vielleicht hatte er zwei Sachen, wer weiß es.
Also ich habe im Moment wirklich so einen jungen Mann, der hat diese Beschwerden.
Das ist also wirklich ein Patient von mir.
Wir versuchen jetzt halt, über eine Woche herauszufinden, was er hat.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wir haben schon einen MRT gemacht, der hat keinen Bandscheiben vorbeifahren.
Jetzt machen wir einen CT und der beschreibt genau diese Schmerzen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Und die Blutuntersuchung war unaufgesehen.
Die Blutuntersuchung war unauffällig.
Die Urinstatus war auch alles unauffällig.
Ja, das haben wir leider noch nicht.
Das hat er nicht gegeben.
Er war immer weg unterwegs.
Wir warten mal, ich bin mal gespannt.
Es könnte sein, vielleicht auch ein Haarenleiter steinen.
Oder er hat ganz was anderes.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe auch bei der Anamese Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen gefragt.
Genau, bisher noch nicht.
Zur weiteren Abkühlung werde ich, wie gesagt,
körperliche Unterzuhund.
Genau, Blutablage und so weiter.
Was könnte man nochmal?
Eine Computertomographie.
Und Urinstatus können wir natürlich.
Genau, das ist wichtig.
Und Sonografie, das Gold Standard bei dieser Erkrankung,
müssen wir, eine Dortmundsonografie können wir auch in Deutschland
in diesem Bereich gucken.
Das müssen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt im Notfall machen,
aber in so einem Ultraschall wäre das ganz gut.
Vielen Dank Herr Dr.
Das war sehr gut.
Auch die Differenzialdiagnosen.
Heute war auch die Mitarbeit der Kollegen sehr gut.
30 Teilnehmer, das ist ja ein neuer Rekord fast schon hier.
Kürzlich war 37.
Sehr schön, ganz toll.
Sehr gut, dann möchte ich mich ganz herzlich bedanken,
auch bei den Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Wir dürfen die Ärztinnen nicht vergessen.
Und deine Prüfung ist nächste Woche?
Nächste Woche am Mittwoch.
Deshalb habe ich diese ganze Woche 7 Tage,
eine Urlaubstage bekommen.
Ab heute.
Ich glaube, das können wir schaffen.
Und ich glaube, das ist eine gute Prüfung.
Wo gehst du in Hessen?
In Reutlingen, in Erstekammer Reutlingen, Baden-Württemberg.
Ach so, also Reutlingen?
Reutlingen, Baden-Württemberg, eine Erstekammer.
Weil du in Baden-Württemberg arbeitest?
Ich arbeite in Wiesnach.
Und das ist Baden-Württemberg, ja.
Genau, Baden-Württemberg, genau.
Deshalb muss ich die Prüfung ablegen.